The details that we're getting.
Do not answer the big questions.
What exactly it is?
Who is the owner of this object?
Considering that they knew about it
last night,
only shot it down
less than 2 hours ago,
and they have not yet retrieved that.
Should we know more now?
Should they know more than they do
Well, Victor, in this particular case,
probably not.
You know, there's always the fog of war,
and in this case,
the fog of the incident.
And what we're dealing with
is a situation where
in the wake of the balloon incident
that happened just
six days ago or so.
So now we're looking at something
that's very,
you know, perhaps a little bit different,
but somewhat similar.
And we're out of an abundance
of political caution.
The craft was was taken out
because it posed.
General Ryder said it posed a threat
to civilian aircraft and could possibly
have also been
some type of a collection platform.
We don't know that yet,
but they decided
they didn't want to take the
chance again.
And as a result,
we have what we have at the moment.
Kelly
Atwood, to you,
the question of who's responsible.
The words that still stick with me
are from John Kirby.
And he said,
I have no idea who owns this.
What do you know about the efforts
happening right now
potentially to find that out?
Of course, the first country
that most people think of is China,
considering that balloon
that just passed over the U.S.
a couple of days ago.
Yeah, that's right.
I mean, I would
think it's fair to say that
there is a widespread effort
to figure out where this came from
and who owns it, because as you said,
you know,
multiple officials
saying today from the White House
and from the Pentagon, the U.S.
doesn't know if this is state owned
or if this is privately owned.
So they're really trying
to figure out who owns this
and where it came from
because they first detected
it just yesterday when it came close
and then into U.S. airspace.
I do think that
there's one
significant thing to point out here,
which is that
with the Chinese spy
balloon, there was a number of contacts
between U.S.
diplomats and Chinese diplomats
before the Biden administration took
the move to shoot it down
off the coast of South Carolina.
The fact that there hasn't
been any back and forth with China,
according to the White House
on this, does
indicate
that perhaps
they don't think it is
Chinese owned,
but of course, they aren't
counting out anything right now.
And what we'll be watching for
is the contacts, particularly
on the diplomatic front, to inform allies
about what happened here
and try and work with Five Eyes.
Those are partners
that we share intelligence
with to figure out
what those countries might know
that could help us.
In addition
to what's going to be
this effort on the ground,
this obviously went down over
this was over frozen water.
So it's going to be a very different
excavation effort.
But that will probably be their best shot
at figuring out the answers
to many of these questions.
We don't know right now.
Let's bring in Oren Liebermann,
our Pentagon correspondent,
who was there in the briefing
or in the Pentagon,
also at the White House.
They're
very careful not to describe this balloon
and part,
as General Ryder said,
simply because he does not know.
But we're learning
that is not similar in size or shape.
To that Chinese surveillance balloon
that was shot down last week.
What stood out to you
from what we just heard
from the Pentagon?
Correct.
Significant differences
simply in how they describe this.
Obviously, we said many times
the previous object
was about the length of three busses,
the balloon itself, some 200 feet tall,
nothing near that size
in terms of the object
that was shot down.
And Pentagon
Press Secretary
Brigadier General Pat
Ryder was very careful
not to describe this in any way
other than saying
it was about a small car sized object
and that it was unmanned.
There wasn't much beyond that
in terms of how it was moving.
Did it have any sort of propulsion
or any sort of maneuverability?
So there are obviously a tremendous
number of questions
in what this was,
frankly, what it looked like,
despite the fact that U.S.
fighter jets and fighter pilots
had eyes on this
since it was first spotted
and then what it was doing right
at the end of the press conference,
the Pentagon said it was moving
in a northeasterly direction.
It had been spotted yesterday
and they'd kept an eye on it since then.
Eventually, the decision was made
to shoot it down.
It had been roughly at the same altitude
throughout the time the U.S.
had eyes on it.
So at about 40,000 feet,
which is roughly
the upper edge of commercial air traffic,
and that Brigadier
General Pat
Ryder said, is
why the decision was ultimately made
to shoot this down.
One of the key questions we asked is
the Pentagon
made a big point of this rider himself
and others as well,
that there was a benefit
to having the other balloon fly
across much of the continental
United States
in terms of intelligence gathering.
If that's the case,
why was this one shot down so quickly
before there was any attempt
at intelligence gathering?
Because the Pentagon described him
in great terms
how much intelligence
they gained from the previous balloon.
In this case.
The Pentagon
simply said that every decision
on every individual object
or every scenario like this
will be decided on an individual basis.
And in this case, partially
because of the threat
to civilian aircraft.
The decision was made to shoot
this one down right at the end.
We also got into the question of
the authorities
to carry out
something like this,
the NORTHCOM,
NORTHCOM Mender would generally
have the authority
to take out
or call a call a fighter jet to take out
an unidentified balloon over U.S.
airspace.
But Ryder said
because this doesn't pose a threat
to anybody below
or an imminent threat
to national security,
the decision went up to the president,
where President
Joe Biden gave his approval
in that case, also worth noting,
as I suspect
others have noted before,
if you were listening
to the press conference,
it was the same type of aircraft
and the same type of missile
that was used to shoot this object down.
Major lines.
Certainly, we're trying to get
as many details about this object,
about the decision
to take it down as possible.
But can we just zoom out for a minute?
This is the second time
in, what, ten days now
that an object has been discovered in US
airspace.
The first when a Chinese spy balloon
shot down.
Still so many questions about this one.
What's your reaction to the breaking news
that we just learned minutes ago
and now just 2 hours ago,
this thing was shot down?
Well, Victor,
it tells me that
they've changed their protocol
in the fact
that they're going to notify
the administration
or put the message out up front
and quickly
decide and engage these targets.
And in a post-9-11
world, that's really
the only thing they can do.
You know, that comment
the Pentagon makes about,
you know,
we wanted to see the last spy balloon
travel across the United States
and get intelligence from it
just frankly doesn't pass
the red face test.
So I think this was a message
that they're sending out to the world
that we've got domain capability
now to see this.
It was at 40,000 feet.
That was commercial airliners.
But when the north commander last week
said, you know, the last balloon
showed some,
you know,
domain weaknesses
there, that's a problem.
We usually don't tell our enemies
where those those gaps are.
So I think this is a message
that was sent by the Pentagon.
They've changed their protocol.
They're going to do this from now on.
This is going to be
normal course of business.
If things violate our airspace. Hmm.
Colonel, back to you.
I'm going to ask you a question
that I assume maybe is tough to answer,
but based on the description we have,
this is the size of a small car.
It was about 40,000 feet non-removable.
And when people here, smart, small cars
don't think of the density of a car,
think of just the size of it.
Is there anything that that you think
that this could be likely is?
We can rule out that this item was
Yeah, that's a great question, Victor.
I think that, you know,
what are the possibilities?
Frankly, there is actually a weather
balloon, you know,
so that
we can't rule that out completely.
The key thing that I focused on
was that apparently this object
did not have the kind of convective
capable ity that the balloon did.
So that becomes a very different issue.
And, you know, to
what Major Lyons was saying, this
there is a big difference
from an intelligence collection
perspective.
It actually is okay in some cases
to collect the information.
See, I would actually talk
to other entities.
In this particular case,
you have a bit of a different situation
where it didn't talk to anything,
but you don't know what a threat it poses
except for the fact that, you know,
it is a threat to commercial aviation.
Hmm.
Natasha, to you, in the intersection
of the military and politics here,
I think
orange question is fair
considering that the argument that to let
the Chinese balloon go across the country
and then shoot it down,
you can collect something from it
One has to question the
potency of the criticism
of the administration
for not shooting it down
early on when it was discovered
that Chinese balloon
and if that influenced
the decision today.
It's an absolutely fair question, Victor.
And I think we should recap a little bit
all of the furor
that's happened over the last week
from Republicans
mainly who have wanted to know
from the Biden administration
why they didn't shoot down
that first Chinese spy balloon
when they saw that it was on a path
towards entering U.S. airspace.
We know that Alaskan
lawmakers in particular
have been pretty angry
with the Biden administration
for allowing this balloon
to cross over Alaska
and then just deciding
that they were going to
watch and monitor it
because they did not think
that it would
actually enter the lower 48.
So that obviously has been taken
by the Biden administration.
They have been
listening to that criticism.
It is completely unclear
at this point, of course,
whether this was a decision that was made
with that kind of criticism in mind.
But it's also important to note here
that we still do
not know whether this item
or this device
actually
has any kind of intelligence value.
It was unmanned,
so it didn't pose any kind of risk to
any human being inside the inside
the object to shoot it down.
But also it didn't pose any threats
to appear to pose any threat
to anyone on the ground.
And it was traveling at an altitude
that could have posed a threat
to civilian aircraft.
So there really was
not as much of a choice here
in what they were going to do
as they had
with the balloon,
which was traveling at around
65,000 feet
and did not appear to pose a real threat
to any any civilians
really, either in the air
or on the ground.
So different situations here.
I think it will be
it'll be clearer
once we actually are able
to see
during these recovery efforts
what this is
whether it was the correct decision.